The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GILBERT STRANG: OK.
Why don't I start?
So I was hoping that we would
have the next online assignment
ready, but Julia 0.6, the new
version, is slowing us down,
and it'll probably be next time.
But my lectures,
of course, are--
well, what I want
to say, perhaps,
is this isn't intended
to be a course
in numerical linear
algebra, but I
thought I couldn't let the whole
semester go by without saying
something about how to compute
eigenvalues and singular
values.
Of course, you're going to call
eig or SVD or the equivalent
in Python or Julia.
But actually, the
QR factorization
that we spoke about, that we
spoke entirely about last time,
is the key--
unexpectedly, unexpectedly.
You have a matrix A whose
eigenvalues you want.
So let's start with eigenvalues.
And it might be a
symmetric matrix.
I'll stay with A rather than S
because it doesn't have to be,
but you get special--
always you get something special
if the matrix is symmetric.
So this method of computing
eigenvalues, to me at least
and I think to many
people, came out
of the blue a while ago,
but not that long ago.
And it worked very well.
So here's the idea.
It's called the QR method
because you start by factoring
your matrix into QR.
So here's A. Can we call it A0?
That's the matrix we start
with whose eigenvalues we want.
And I'll call these Q0 and R0.
And you remember
what that means,
what's hiding behind those
letters that I've written?
You have the columns of A,
possibly symmetric as I said,
but not orthogonal usually.
So you find an orthogonal basis.
You orthogonalize--
you line them up
perpendicular to each other.
And then there is
a matrix R, which
happens to be upper
triangular, that
connects the
not-orthogonal basis
with the orthogonality base.
Right.
We constructed R step-by-step.
And then, the idea is write
these in the reverse order,
and that will be A1, the next A.
And then do it again and again
and again.
And so we're hoping, of course,
that the eigenvalues didn't
change.
We're hoping that we can
forget A0, start again with A1,
and produce A2 and continue.
So we're hoping two things.
One will not be a hope.
We can see that the eigenvalues
of A1 and A0 are the same.
So we have not changed
the eigenvalues.
How do we see that?
If you had to show
that two matrices had
the same eigenvalues, would
you compute all the eigenvalues
and compare them?
Certainly not.
What would you do?
What's the best test, the
usual test, the usual thing
you would want to show to--
AUDIENCE: They're similar.
GILBERT STRANG: They're
similar, that's right.
So the claim would be that
these two matrices are similar.
Right.
So maybe we should show that.
So we want to write
A1 in a different way.
So the claim is A1
is similar to A.
So we just have to figure out--
we have to get A1
and turn it to A0.
So here is A1.
So A1.
I want to show
that that's right.
So that's R0, Q0.
But what is Q0?
From here, Q0 is what we--
Q0 is-- what do I want?
I want to put R0
inverse over there.
So R0.
Now for Q0, I'm
going to substitute.
So what is Q0?
I multiply both sides of
that equation by R0 inverse.
So Q0 is A0 is-- sorry, I said
A and wrote Q. A0, R0 inverse.
For Q0, I've put
in what it equals.
And that's done it.
That's exactly telling me that
A1 which is this, equals this,
and that's a similarity
transformation.
I have not changed
the eigenvalues.
So that's OK.
The other thing, which
is the, you could say,
the miracle in this
thing, is that when
I continue to do that
for almost every matrix,
the matrices begin to lose
stuff off the diagonal,
especially below the diagonal by
the ordering that QR has done.
So it would tend to--
you start with a matrix A0.
You got a matrix A1, which
is a little smaller here.
This part being
especially smaller.
You do it again.
This is even smaller.
Even smaller.
A2.
And you keep going.
And for most matrices,
the result is that--
I don't know how many steps
we want to think of taking,
but we get quite small
numbers here, especially--
yeah.
So once we get small numbers
here, little epsilons--
that's everybody's shorthand
for small numbers--
what would you expect
to see on the diagonal?
AUDIENCE: The eigenvalues.
GILBERT STRANG: The
eigenvalues, because this
has the same
eigenvalues as this,
as this, as this, and
these little epsilons
are not going to change
the eigenvalues too much.
So these will be,
on the diagonal,
will be close to
the eigenvalues.
And actually, what happens
is this one comes first.
That one is quite
accurate first.
I guess we should probably
do a simple example
to see this happen.
Actually, I do an
example in the notes.
And let me say what happens.
So I do a 2 by 2 example
which has something
like cos theta, sine theta.
I don't know what--
I've forgotten what I took, and
I don't have that page of notes
here.
Something here, something
here, something here as A0.
And, then A1, after
just one step,
has sine cubed theta
there and numbers there
that are getting much
closer to the eigenvalues.
Sorry that this isn't
a full-scale example,
but the point of
the example is here,
that this off-diagonal
entry gets cubed.
And the next step will be
its 9th power, and then
the 27th power.
So it's really
quickly going to 0.
And this happens-- so
cubic convergence is--
that's a price in
numerical linear algebra.
So that happens.
So this arrived on
the scene and quickly
blew away all other
methods that were being
used to compute eigenvalues.
But numerical people,
being what they are,
they wanted to improve it--
like, is there a way
to make it faster?
And it turned out there is.
It turned out that
the better way--
basically, the same
idea, but just you're
always looking for
a simple change.
And the idea of
introducing a shift
was tried and turned out
to work extremely well.
So that's the improvement.
So we take A1--
no.
So how does it--
how does the shift work?
So instead of A1--
have I got space
here to do this?
Instead of A0, I take
A1 minus a shift.
So a shift is some
multiple of the identity.
If I just move a matrix by
a multiple of the identity,
what happens to
its eigenvectors?
What happens to its eigenvalues?
Something pretty simple,
right, because I'm just
shifting by sI.
What happens to
its eigenvectors?
AUDIENCE: They stay the same.
GILBERT STRANG:
They're the same.
And what happens
to the eigenvalues?
AUDIENCE: They change by s.
GILBERT STRANG:
They change by s.
If A0 V equaled lambda v, then
when I multiply this by V,
there will be an extra--
it'll be lambda minus s because
the identity times the V
is just V. So it just shifts
all the eigenvalues by s.
And you try to shift--
you look for a shift.
This would be great.
If you knew lambda
N, a shift there,
you would be looking for
0 then if you shifted them
all by that lambda.
And it turns out that
would speed things up.
So it will work instead
with this matrix as now,
again, I'm factoring
it in a Q0 R0.
So that's the work of the
method is in doing Gram-Schmidt
at every step.
And then there's a little
work in reversing the order.
And then I want
to undo the shift,
so I do that factorization.
Now, let's see.
You may have to help me to
remember what I should do here.
So I factor those.
I reverse those.
And then I think I add back
the shift, and that's my A1.
So I took A0.
I shifted it.
I worked with it.
QR.
Reversed the order.
RQ.
Added back the shift
to get a matrix.
And what am I, of course, hoping
about the matrix A1 and A0?
I'm hoping they're
still similar.
So I did a shift
and I undid a shift.
But of course, after doing
our QR, I have to check,
are these really still similar?
So let me just try to
check that one again.
Maybe I'll just-- it's
sitting right there,
so let me do it again.
I'm hoping something--
where did we--
oh yeah, here.
We show that A1
was similar to A0,
and I'm hoping that's
probably still true even--
the shift didn't mess that up.
Let's just try.
So A0-- that's R0, Q0 plus sI.
And now what am I going to do?
I'm going to-- what
did I do before?
I figured out what
Q0 was from this.
You remember?
So this R0.
Now I have to put in Q0.
But Q0 is this thing
inverse times this.
Is this going to work?
I'm hoping, but I don't
think I wanted to get that.
No, it's not Q0 there.
What do I put it here?
And if it doesn't work, we'll
leave it as an exercise.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GILBERT STRANG: Yeah, because
I didn't start right somehow.
But let me just push
along to see what happens.
So I'm plugging in for Q0 here.
I'm plugging in this matrix,
so it's shouldn't have
inverted it, times R0 inverse.
Who knows?
It might work.
So that's the R0, Q0.
Right?
Is everybody with me?
Sorry about the--
R0 inverse.
And then I have to add sI.
So what have I done?
I've just pushed on,
believing that this
would work because it's the
method that is constantly used.
Now, do I have--
what do I have there?
Is it working?
This is R0 A. That
was, of course, A0.
R0, A0, R0 inverse.
Good.
Minus s.
What have I got there
from the R0 minus sI R0?
What is that?
AUDIENCE: Minus sI.
GILBERT STRANG: That's minus sI.
Ha, look.
Success.
The R0 cancels the R0 inverse.
So that term from that,
that, that is minus sI
cancels plus sI.
I'm finished.
And lo and behold, we
have the same similarity.
So we messed around by a
multiple of the identity,
and it didn't--
it actually makes the
thing converge faster
if we choose the shifts well.
But basically, the same
idea is still working.
So that's the QR method.
Well, that's the method.
We haven't shown and
won't show that--
except for this
half-completed example,
I don't plan to prove that the
lower triangular part begins
to disappear, gets smaller
and smaller and smaller,
and then the eigenvalues
pop up on the diagonal.
It's amazing.
Amazing.
Now, is there any other
improvement we can make?
So that's the method.
And where is the work
in using that method?
Because that's what
we always focus on.
Where are we spending
computer time?
Well, we're spending
computer time
in doing the factorization.
So it didn't cost anything
to shift by the identity,
but then we had to
factor that into Q0, R0.
Then it didn't cost
much to multiply them
in the opposite order.
So the work was in QR.
So could we think of anything
to improve that aspect?
Can we think of anything there?
And then we've got a
really first class method.
Well, the matrix A--
A0, the matrix we started with--
had some zeros that
allowed us to skip steps
in doing the QR factorization.
So what am I going to say?
I'm going to say if A or
A0, our original matrix,
has a bunch of zeros--
let's say it's got a
whole lot of zeros there.
Maybe it's--
Well, OK.
I overdid it here.
I know the
eigenvalues right off.
But so the truth is I can't--
saying that if that is
not going to happen.
But we can get zeros
with one extra diagonal.
That turns out-- so here
is the main diagonal.
Everybody's got his eye
on the main diagonal.
And one diagonal--
I can get a lot of zeros, but
I can't by simple computations.
And I'll show you
how to get one.
But I can't get
all those to be 0,
because then I would have
the eigenvalues right there.
Well, how do I
know that I can't?
In elimination, ordinary
solving AX equal B,
you really do get to an
upper triangular form.
Some operator, some elimination
steps you plug away,
and your matrix becomes upper
triangular U and you're golden.
But that's too much
to expect here.
In fact, we know we can't
do it by simple steps
because if we could do
it, if we could get to a U
with a whole lower
triangular part 0,
we would have found
the eigenvalues.
And we know that the
eigenvalues solve a system--
solve an equation of nth degree.
And we know-- somebody proved
a century or more ago--
that you can't solve
an nth degree equation
by simple little steps.
Do you know who that
was and that you
know that fact and what
degree does it apply to?
So that's an important fact
that you pick up in math.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The 5th [INAUDIBLE].
GILBERT STRANG:
5th degree, yeah.
So 5 by 5 and up would be--
this is impossible.
Impossible.
There is no formula to find a
simple formula for the lambdas.
And similarly for the
sigmas for singular values.
So the eigenvalues
is definitely a level
of difficulty beyond AX
equal B, the inverse matrix,
or something, that pivots.
All that you can do exactly if
you're doing exact arithmetic.
We cannot find the
lambdas exactly,
but we can get as close as we
like by continuing with the QR
method.
So yeah.
In other words, we can't--
we have to settle for--
if we want to, like
at the beginning,
improve our matrix before
we start doing that stuff,
we can get it with
one extra diagonal.
And do you know what kind
of a matrix, whose name--
I don't know why.
AUDIENCE: Upper Hessenberg.
GILBERT STRANG: Yeah.
Say it again.
AUDIENCE: Upper Hessenberg.
GILBERT STRANG:
Upper Hessenberg.
So upper is just like
upper triangular.
It's up there.
But key person's
name is Hessenberg.
As I say, that's a
Hessenberg matrix.
So Hessenberg matrix is a
matrix with one triangular
plus one more diagonal,
but lots of zeros.
Order of N squared.
Something like almost
like half N squared--
not quite, but close--
zeros.
And you could show those
zeros stay zeros in QR.
So that really pays off.
It cuts the work
down significantly.
So that's the-- full
QR method is Step 1--
reduce A to Hessenberg
form with these zeros.
And when I say reduce,
I mean find a similarity
transformation, of
course, because I
want the eigenvalues of this to
end up the same as the Hessen.
I want to keep the same
eigenvalues as I go.
And then, Step 2 is QR on this
Hessenberg matrix with shifts.
So that's the code that would
be programmed in eig(A).
That's what Matlab and--
well really, Matlab
is appealing--
like other matrix systems--
is appealing to
LAPACK and LINPACK.
A team of professional
numerical analysts
really spent a lot
of effort and time.
The book LAPACK has
10 authors, and you
can download any of these
codes, like the eigenvalue code.
So that's where
Matlab, naturally--
that's the Bible for
code in linear algebra.
I think it's
interesting to know.
And there's one more good thing
to tell you about this method.
And it applies if the
matrix is symmetric.
If the matrix is symmetric,
then if we check all this,
we could find that the
matrices stayed symmetric.
If A0 is symmetric,
I can check--
you could easily
check through this
and you would discover
that A1 is also symmetric.
It turns out you
could rewrite this
with a Q0 in a Q0 inverse
on the other side,
but that Q0 inverse is
the same as Q0 transposed
because it's an
orthogonal matrix,
and symmetry would fall out.
So if it's symmetric, and
it's in his Hessenberg form
and it stays symmetric
at every step,
what can you tell me about a
symmetric Heisenberg matrix?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GILBERT STRANG: It's only got--
yeah.
You just erase all these.
If they are zeros there and
if the matrix is symmetric,
then we can safely
predict that it will only
have one diagonal
above, one non-zero
diagonal above
the main diagonal.
In fact, it will say symmetric.
So now I should write
"symmetric Hessenberg matrix,"
and equals tridiagonal matrix.
Three diagonals.
So now you really
have reduced the time
to do QR because you've
got a tridiagonal matrix.
It'll stay tridiagonal
in all these steps.
So you're working with
just three N numbers.
Well actually, two N because the
diagonal above and the diagonal
below are the same.
You're working with just two
N numbers instead of order N
squared, and it just
goes like a bomb.
So that's eig for
symmetric matrices.
And you see that
it was all based--
that really the heart
of the algorithm was QR.
So that's my-- that
took half the class
to report on the favorite
way, the eig way,
to find eigenvalues.
Oh, I should say something
about singular values.
So singular values.
Of course, the singular
values of the matrix
are the eigenvalues
of A transpose A--
square root of
those eigenvalues.
But you wouldn't do it that way.
You would never
form A transpose A.
Oh, I didn't mention the
other thing you would never,
ever, ever do, so let me just
put it here like in disgrace.
To solve that equation is
like, OK, back to first grade,
because that's not--
that's very bad.
A determinant-- first of all,
it's extremely slow-- extremely
slow.
And the determinant is packing
all this N squared pieces
of information
into N coefficient,
and it's hopelessly
ill conditioned.
Yeah.
You lose information
all the time.
So really, if this
is going on camera,
it better go on camera with
an x, because you don't do it.
Yeah.
So where was I?
Singular values.
So A transpose A.
So again, let's
think about what you
could do at the beginning
before starting on
QR for A transpose A
or for the matrix
A. What could you
do with orthogonal matrices?
So I guess-- what did we say
about symmetric matrices?
So here's what I said
about symmetric matrices.
If you'll give me
a symmetric matrix,
I can in just a simple
number of simple steps
make it tridiagonal.
I can't make it diagonal
because then I'd
be finding the eigenvalues and
Abel, who was the first person
to see that that was
impossible, forbids it.
So let me let me write
down what I'm saying here.
If I have a
symmetric matrix S, I
can find a bunch of
Qs and Q transposes,
and I can put them all
together into one big Q,
and it's transposed.
And what do I know about the
eigenvalues of that matrix?
Q is orthogonal always.
So what can you
tell me about the--
this is the same as QSQ inverse,
and therefore the eigenvalues
are the same.
It's similar to S. And it
becomes tridiagonal After?
I find a good Q.
Therefore, same lambdas.
It's tridiagonal with
the same lambdas.
Now, what am I
thinking about here?
I'm thinking about-- tell me
the corresponding possibility
about singular values.
I wanted to do
something to my matrix.
Now, I'm always taking
a general matrix A.
And I'm looking for
its singular values.
And I'm looking to simplify it.
And what am I allowed to do?
Yeah, I guess my question is--
similarity transformations
left the eigenvalues alone.
What can I do that leaves
the singular values alone?
That's a fundamental question
because it was so fundamental
for eigenvalues.
By doing this, a
matrix and its inverse,
I got something similar,
and I checked even
in this class that the
eigenvalues, same lambdas.
Now I want a whole line that
ends up with the same sigmas.
And I want you to tell me what
I'm allowed to do to the matrix
without changing the sigmas.
So this is a--
maybe don't shout
it out immediately.
Let everybody think.
What am I allowed
to do to a matrix?
Every matrix has got
these singular values,
and now I want to make
it a better matrix
with more zeros or something.
If I do that to it, does
that change the sigmas?
Can I do more than that to it?
What can I do?
What group of matrices
will have the same sigmas
as my starting matrix A?
So that's a basic, basic
question about singular values
and the SVD.
So let's think of
the answer together.
So it's connected to the SVD,
so let me remember the SVD.
The SVD-- I have some
orthogonal matrix.
Then the singular
value of the matrix--
SV for singular values.
And then another
orthogonal matrix.
What could I do to that equation
that would not touch this guy?
So I'm asking, what invariants?
Because not touching it
means leaving it not varying.
So I'm looking for under what
operations are the singular
values invariant?
When I was looking
at eigenvalues,
this was the operation.
Well, it didn't have
to be orthogonal--
something, then its inverse.
But now, what is it up there?
What could I do
to that matrix A?
Could I multiply it by Q?
Could I throw in a Q maybe
not even on the other end?
If I throw in an orthogonal Q,
do I change the singular values
or do I not change them?
Fundamental question.
The answer is no, I
don't change them.
I'm allowed to do.
That because here's
an orthogonal matrix,
a Q times U. If both of
those are orthogonal,
then the product is.
Everybody knows that a product
of two orthogonal matrix
is still orthogonal.
Better know that.
So if I have an
orthogonal matrix Q
and an orthogonal
matrix U, I claim
that this is still orthogonal.
And how do I check it?
Well, I use some test
for orthogonality.
What would be the--
what test do you like to use?
The inverse is the
same as that transpose,
do you like that test?
So I'll invert it.
QU inverse.
Of course, for any matrix
that's U inverse, Q inverse.
But these were
separately orthogonal,
so that's U transpose
Q transpose.
And that is the same
as QU transpose.
So I used the orthogonality of
U and the orthogonality of Q
to conclude that the
inverse is the transpose.
So the answer is
yes, I could do that.
Now, with singular value--
with eigenvalues, I had to
multiply on the other side
by Q inverse or Q transpose.
Do I have to do that now?
No.
What can I do on
the right-hand side?
I can multiply by--
I can leave it alone.
Then it has the same
singular values because it's
the same sigma in there.
If I have a orthogonal
matrix times a diagonal
times an orthogonal,
that diagonal is--
positive diagonal is
going to be sigma.
So what can I do on this side?
I can multiply by any orthogonal
matrix on that side too.
So let's call this guy
Q1 and this guy Q2.
I still have an
orthogonal matrix there,
and the same sigma
popped in the middle.
So that's what
you're allowed to do.
That gives us more freedom.
Before we got-- when we had to
do similarity transformations
with the same guy, we
got it to be tridiagonal.
But now, we're allowed
to do more stuff.
We're allowed to use different
orthogonal matrices on the left
and right.
And we can reduce
it even further
from tridiagonal to bidiagonal.
So the first step
is getting zero.
The step of getting zeros
reduces it all the way
to that, with all zeros there.
So it's easier.
Then I work on this.
This is the matrix I
work on using a QR type
idea, some method like that.
So everybody's seeing that our
algorithm has got two stages.
One is get a lot of
zeros and get them
in places that will stay zero
as Part 2 of the algorithm
gets going.
And then, run Part
2 of the algorithm.
You staying with-- each
step is very fast now
because doing a QR
factorization is fast.
Was there a question?
Yeah.
So I would call this
bidiagonal, of course.
And everybody recognizes that
if I have a bidiagonal matrix--
call it A or A0 or whatever--
then what do you think
about A transpose A?
What would A transpose
A-- if that was A,
what could you tell me
about A transpose A?
Could you multiply matrices
knowing where the non-zeros are
in your head and get
an idea of where--
and so if I have a bidiagonal
matrix A, then implicitly
in the SVD, I'm looking
at A transpose A.
And what would be true
about A transpose A?
It would be tridiagonal.
So what I've done here and what
I've done there just match up.
You can operate-- if you don't
want to change singular values,
you can get all the way to here.
But then, to find those
singular values, that
would involve A
transpose A. It would
be symmetric and tridiagonal,
and then you'd be in that game.
So those are the basic
facts of eig and SVD
for matrices of order
up to 1,000, say.
I'm not enough of an
expert to know where--
Maybe higher, because
in perfect math,
it's going to take
infinitely many steps
or Abel would be very surprised.
He would see you solving for
eigenvalues an nth degree
equation by a whole
lot of little steps
and getting them exactly right.
That won't happen.
But you get them within
epsilon in a number
of steps that's like N cubed.
So that's pretty impressive.
The eigenvalue problem
is being "solved,"
in quotes, by a fast
method that gets
you a good answer within a
tolerance in N cube steps.
So that's great as long
as N isn't too big.
And then, when N is too big--
which, of course, happens--
you have to think again.
So this method is a giant
success up to large matrices,
but then you have
to think again.
And what is involved
in thinking again?
Well, I guess more thinking.
So what do you do if
the matrix is bigger?
I guess that Krylov
would say, use my method.
So Krylov would say-- especially
if your matrix was sparse.
Can we just remember
what Krylov was?
Krylov started with a
vector b, multiplied it
by A, multiplied that
by A, and got up to,
let's say, A to the 999b.
So now he's got--
Krylov has got
1,000-dimensional space.
He's got a basis for it--
1,000 vectors that span
1,000-dimensional space.
And he'll look at the
matrix A only on that space.
In other words--
I won't go into
detail about that.
He restricts the matrix to
this 1,000-dimensional space,
and he hopes that it's captured.
We hope that the
eigenvector is almost--
is virtually in that space.
And actually, I wouldn't go to--
let me take a 9 out of that.
100-dimensional would probably
catch the eigenvector.
So if the eigenvector is
virtually in this space,
then we can look at a
matrix of order 100.
We can bring A down to just
see its action on that space.
And any piece of--
so here is a-- so
I look at vectors
v, which are some combination--
c1 b plus c2 Ab plus c3 A
squared b, and c100
A to the 99th b.
Plus an error.
And I'm going to ignore
that error because I've
gone up to dimension 100.
I'd probably say it's pretty
safe to ignore that error.
And then, in this space,
just looking at the matrix
A-- so wherever A to the
100th comes in, forget it.
Just think about the matrix
A as multiplying vectors
of this kind in this space.
Then I have 100 by 100
eigenvalue problem.
And so the big matrix A is
reduced to a matrix of size 100
by--
do you see what I'm saying even?
So I'm not giving the details.
Think of a matrix A
of size a million.
And you apply it
to Krylov vectors--
so I call them little
k for a Krylov vector--
in this 100-dimensional space.
So they have a million
minus 100 0-components,
you could say, this k.
This is in the Krylov space.
This is A, a million--
k, 100.
It's a full-- so it's
got a million components,
but it's out of just
100-dimensional space.
So when I multiply by
A, it'll be mostly in--
partly in the Krylov space--
k100-- and a piece out of k100.
And I just ignore that
part of the matrix.
So I have 100 by
100 problem, and I
solve to find the eigenvalues.
And they're a pretty
good approximation
to the eigenvalues,
to the, hopefully,
like the lowest 100 eigenvalues.
I'd like to know
that, but I might not
be sure that this
idea would give me
the lowest 100-- the first 100
eigenvalues of the million,
of the matrix of size a million.
I'm just taking a few
minutes here to wave hands
about what Krylov idea would do.
And I probably won't mention
Krylov again in this semester.
So what it can do is look at
this particular type of space
because we can get a
basis for it quickly.
Just multiply again
and again by A. Then we
can orthogonalize that basis.
That's Gram-Schmidt
in some form.
We're always going
back to Gram-Schmidt.
Then I have 100 by 100--
I have a subspace of size 100.
I look at what the matrix
does in that space,
and that I could look for--
I could find eigenvalues
restricted to that space.
They wouldn't be the
perfect eigenvalues,
but they would be accurate.
So I didn't know it would
take one class time to talk
about finding eigenvalues
and singular values,
but we did some
important things.
We remembered that similarity
is the thing to check,
thing to preserve, because it
doesn't change the eigenvalues.
And then we-- for singular
values, what was the thing?
You could multiply
left and right
by different
orthogonal matrices.
And somehow, maybe that doesn't
have an established name,
multiplying left and right
by a Q1 and a Q2 transpose.
But the idea is clear,
and that doesn't
change the singular values.
We're ready to move now into--
maybe our next step, which we
don't spend a long time on,
will be random sampling.
What if your matrix
is just way too big?
So that's a very new
idea, very different idea
in numerical linear algebra,
is just to sample the matrix.
Could you believe
that the answer
is going to come out right
just for a random sample?
Well, the odds
are in your favor.
So that will be
Wednesday, and then we
have lots of new-- we'll
move onward after that.
See you Wednesday.
Thanks.